[Music]
hello YouTube just love us my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
sixth episode of quaint rap sak lines in
this episode I'm going to show you a
wonderful Queen sacrifice line in 2c3
Sicilian from the black perspective the
opening arises after the following order
efore c5 c3 and the line which we are
going to continue start with defy main
line continues with ecaps is defy Queen
captures defy and now it doesn't matter
whether your opponent continued with
Knight to f3 or d4 let's say in this
game
white continue with d4 first and after
the move Knight to c6 he continued it
like to have three now as per the theory
the most frequent choice from the black
is either Knight to f6 or Bishop to g4
however as usual I am going to suggest a
very tricky and a surprising move Bishop
to a5 in fact this is a very rare guest
in this line this modern move is
recently come into the limelight and has
happened in many case if white continue
with the main line then he will get into
the trouble very very quickly okay
Bishop to e3 over protecting the d4 pawn
Knight to f6 and now as per the latest
database the most frequent choice from
the white is either Knight - III or
Knight B to d2 and in both the case
black get a very comfortable middle game
in this video we are going to
concentrate on the Moon Knight B to d2
however if you opponent continue it
Knight to a3 then I have attached a
sample line in the PGA
which will give you a very good idea how
to play such a positions Knight B to d2
and the idea is very simple white wants
to develop a bishop with a tempo and
continue with his lightning fast
development so question is should we
move the Queen na we should equally play
a tricky move C captures D form and now
White has two choices either to capture
on d4 or play the mainline move Bishop
to c4
now the capturing on d4 square is very
bad for white for example if he captured
with the C pawn then he has this
isolated Queen pawn which later on
become target for all black pieces and
instead of capturing with the pawn if he
continued capturing with piece
for example Knight captures d4 then we
have Knight captures d4 Bishop captures
d4 ePHI Bishop to e3 and now simple
Bishop to e7 and not only black is far
ahead in development but white pieces
are completely cramped
the third option Bishop captures d4 is
not good either the simple reason is
after Bishop captures d4 Knight captures
d4 no matter however white recapture
black obtained the bishop pair and in
the long run this factor do comes a lot
in open game so considering all this
fact majority of the white player at
this position continue with Bishop to c4
which is very natural developing a piece
and attacking the Queen except there is
one problem that this move leads to the
instant disaster I know probably you
already guessed black snakes reply which
is very obvious BAM
so sacrificing the whole Queen and white
doesn't have any second option Bishop
captures defy what else and now comes
pawn captures d2 check and white
responses force in order to protect the
bishop but has to capture with the Queen
and at first sight it looks like black
doesn't have enough compensation because
he only get two minor piece for the
Queen but here comes the sting and the
tail castle on the Queen side and now by
force black is going to get the third
piece for Queen and every chess
professional knows that three minor
piece against Queen is a decisive
winning SH in most of the position the
good point from black perspective is
there are only 30 games played from this
position and the result of the blacks
are tremendous in this line now as I
have highlighted over here mainly White
has tried these three options and
neither of them provide any comfort to
the white camp I have attached full
games of these variations in the PGN so
you can check it out and get an idea how
comfortably and easily black and win
from these positions
the first more I want to look at is c4
which is in fact the most critical move
in this position and has been played in
a recent game between 220 200 plus rated
player where White's idea is after black
plays a6 try to get the third piece
white can continue with Queen to f4 so
wide is saying if you grab our Bishop
the I'll grab your Bishop and you don't
have enough compensation and yes indeed
it's true but the game continuation will
show you with accurate play you can get
your piece easily so in the game black
continue with Bishop to d6 attacking the
Queen Queen to g5
still keeping eye on the bishop and now
comes Bishop to b4 check kindly note
white cannot block the check with the
knight the simple reason is after Knight
captures d5 pawn captures defy rook
captures defy so black is attacking the
knight so wide response is force it has
to support it with rook to d1 but after
rook s to d8
it's a confirmation that that piece is
going off the board and so as White's
came
you
so it is very obvious that white King
has to come forward to the e2 square and
after that black can continue with the
room at six
once again hitting the Queen Queen
captures g7 counter attacking the knight
Knight to h5 attacking the Queen and now
in order to keep attacking
what has the only move that is Queen
captures f7 but there comes Knight to f4
check King to e3 Knight captures g2
check King to e2 Knight to f4 check King
to e3 and after rook as to afaid finally
black managed to preserve his bishop and
that means White's light square Bishop
is going into the coffin forever the
important tactical point behind is still
white cannot take the piece the simple
reason is after Bishop to e4 discover
check King to e3 Bishop captures f3 rook
to g1 and rook D to e a check white king
can hardly survive in this monstrous
attacking position by black the second
mood try by the white is to castle on
the Kings side which in fact played in a
recent game between Jordan and Solomon
where black simply snap up the bishop
with rook captures defy and as you can
see by the arrows black has a very
simple plan he wants to play a six
Bishop to d6 rook to d8 and then create
attack on the D file there are few games
played from this position and you can
check them all in the database but in
this game white plays the move Queen to
e2 which is already a big time mistake
because after the move Bishop to d3
white loses one of his rook and game
only lasts for the 23 moves
the hard move white can try over here is
Bishop captures c6 which in fact played
by none other than c3 Sicilian expert
Sergey T via KHOU but even he cannot
stop blacks demolition job in this line
his opponent Sanchez continued with Luke
kept his d2 white give this check and
after King captures b7 and in the game
he played King captures d2 but it
doesn't matter whether white continued
with either of the capture the sample
lines are available in the PG n which
will highlight how comfortable blacks
position is King captures D to e six and
you can easily see that black has two
bishops against rook and pawn and has
happened in many case bishop pair can
easily outplayed van rook and upon no
surprise that TV echo lost in just 23
moves with a crushing win for the black
well I hope you enjoy and learn this
surprising and tricky Queen sacrifice
line against to c3 Sicilian 1c opponent
plays Bishop to c4 don't miss the
opportunity to sacrifice the Queen with
D captures III and with some good
research you can snatch many points in
this line
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on this video and I'll meet you in my
next episode
very soon bye and take care